you can do whatever you want whatever
you want just put me out of my misery
lady suck my brain on my quest Explorer
curry in New York City the one thing
that stands out to me is the definition
of courage changes so much from country
to country it seems that every culture
has their own version of curry even if
it goes by a different name which is why
I'm so fascinated by some Filipino
dishes that looks smell and tastes just
like curry even if the menus around the
city don't tell yourself I'm headed to
maharloka in the East Village to try and
unpack some of my burning curry
questions with the hilarious comedian
and food for jo koy so you don't really
always see curry on a Filipino menu so
what would you define as a curry even to
this day I really don't know what a
curry is there's so many different
styles of curry to me growing up I just
thought the coconut broth was a curry
you know like you don't know when you're
a kid it's just that was our food it's
not until you get older you go
oh there's influence here there's a
reason why that that spice is here and
the dish is called Bicol Express like it
doesn't even say Korean let you read the
description of that you see like okay I
think it's the only plate with the word
Express in it
I don't even know where that came from
it's on that train that picked up all
the yes it's like all aboard the Bicol
Express is coming from India and it's
got shrimp in it we're gonna hop on that
crazy train in a bit I love it I
oh I was thinking about another song
okay oh come on ride that chain no I
think you're right
ride that beat Coltrane is write it but
before we get there yeah we're gonna try
a couple other dishes so are you ready
to eat
man that's all Filipinos do with eat
first up we have Mahalo cos flip chicken
and ube waffles the dishes made with
batter less fried chicken pieces and
purple yam waffles oh my god this my
friend is what you call boob a waffles
and then this butter I don't think I've
ever had it but it's called um butter
mom go go go go oh okay soy and shrimp
paste and in battle this chicken
like literally it's fabulous like that's
how my mom made chicken at the house man
it just salted put some seasoning on it
and then fry the [ __ ] out of it oh my
god you don't need the batter you get
the crispy dish from the skin mmm all
the flavors in that juice this is
definitely a soul food dish you know I
mean checking them off with this soul
food and what I always said about
Filipino food it's comfort food it's
kind of like soul food it really is so
to see this little fusion right here
where it's not bad or chicken but it's
fried chicken you know main and it's not
waffles but it's all a waffle it's kind
of cool that they put this together
save room because we got two more dishes
on the way are you ready to eat more
let's go let's go
next up we have toasty look see look is
a garlic fried rice dish served with a
fried egg and then that toasty no is a
pork tenderloin cured with 7up alright
first I'm going to show you how to eat
it properly okay let's get the lesson I
like to mix the egg up okay to the rice
I like to get that yellow so the spoon
is like a knife yes the food is the
knife exactly you should have seen Sean
Sean was ridiculous
so I was like this big like yeah so
you're like drumsticks he's holding like
this not like this
what are you doing time you ready and
did you like the sweetness of the board
the meat is really good but there's this
love that Filipino culture has for
Americanized product yeah like spam
banana ketchup yeah 7up where does that
route from the Philippines is like a hub
it's like Grand Central Station you know
I mean all these different ethnicities
stopped by if the Philippines and
dropped off their luggage and then they
took off again and then the Filipinos
like well what can we do with all of
these the 7up put it in there Oh
coconut put it in there the noodles from
China the tamarind from Spain it's like
it's pretty cool to see how we're so
different but when it's all put on the
plate man it works all together we're
about to get to the main event the last
dish but before we do we're gonna toss
through the kitchen and find out what
we're eating
hi my name is Nicole pancetta and one of
the owners here at Maharlika I can't say
that I am the biggest expert on curry
but I do think that I have an idea of
how we define it and how curry winds up
in Filipino cuisine for me traditionally
I think a curry has some sort of spice
that is dried or ground and then infused
in a vehicle like an oil or a broth and
mixed with vegetables or some sort of
protein for me that's like the
rudimentary definition of what a curry
is and the Philippines the closest
approximation to that are two editions
widely known as Bicol Express or ketika
day today we did Bicol Express with
head-on prawns the way we make Bicol
Express I actually learned in the region
of Bicol and it involves sweating
aromatics like ginger garlic onion what
we call CLA or you might refer to as
bird's eye chili and a long pepper which
I refer to as a banana chili and you
sweat all of that down you what you want
to do is really infuse the oil that's
where all the flavor is gonna come from
and when you add the coconut milk you're
adding flavor upon flavor upon flavor I
use two kinds of chili because the
sensation of heat is what I'm going
after so I want to feel the heat in the
front of my tongue and then the kick in
the back it's bomb it's usually done
with pork but sometimes I like to
lighten it up I like to go against the
grain and I'll do shrimp or even I've
done it with a cauliflower it's super
good now the bait of egg sit are you
ready
we're gonna get the entire prawn but we
also left the head there because that's
where you suck the juices you gonna suck
that shrimp brain because that's where
all the seasoning and yumminess is let's
enjoy let's enjoy this shrimp so do I go
that way in my mouth you can do whatever
you want
whatever you want just put me out of my
misery lady suck my brain I want to see
part
okay you're really suck yeah yep bite
down bite don't bite it to a brace just
bite it down and then I'm in second yes
taste that taste that you know what that
was
shrimp brain shrimp headache the food
world has lots of riddles is a hot dog a
sandwich is a stew a curry does this fit
the idea of what a curry is I think so
so is like a Texas chili a curry rule is
a gumbo a curry I would say Adolfo's
occurring is menudo
aperi beeps - curry it's a cold curry
this coleslaw a salad effect is bloating
a meat you [ __ ] love Bologna if you
get cream of chicken and put some
cayenne pepper in it and some coconut
meat is that a curry I say yes
[Music]
whatever you want to call curry we know
it's awesome because it's a fusion of
different spices and stories and love
and it was delicious it was delicious
well thanks for joining us Joe I love
you and oh thanks yeah that was weird
you can check out his Netflix special
and he's on tour right now sand you
better catch it nice and I'm getting
ready to shoot another Netflix special
that exciting well thank you love you
love you Joe
yes
[Music]
my aunt will suck this whole thing god